Trascrizione: Anna Cristiana Minoli
Revisore: Elena Montrasio
Come va? Tutto bene?
Sono contento
che mi abbiano già presentato
perché fi solito per me,
il momento della presentazione
è un momento un po’ difficile.
Perché quando ci presentiamo,
oltre al nome e al cognome,
una delle prime cose che diciamo
è, appunto, cosa facciamo.
E, nel mio caso, la gente
si aspetta una sola cosa.
Già se fai più di una cosa,
li destabilizzi un po'
e, non solo, si aspetta qualcosa
che abbia un nome ben preciso.
Faccio l’arrotino, faccio l’avvocato,
faccio il fornaio.
Quando io devo dire
che mi occupo di giochi,
non so mai come dirlo.
Perché potrei dire,
"faccio il game designer",
però game designer, siete d’accordo,
è troppo americano.
Potrei dire che faccio
il creatore di giochi.
Però creatore di giochi
ha troppe erre, non mi viene bene.
Vedete che non mi viene bene.
Quindi di solito la butto là,
dico "faccio giochi", così.
Soltanto che qui si innesca
tutta una serie di equivoci
e di incomprensioni
che veramente si ripetono molto spesso
e sono anche divertenti.
La prima cosa che la gente pensa,
quando io dico faccio giochi, è questa.
No, non è che gioco. Non è che..
Io faccio il gioco.
“Ah, ho capito, ho capito, fai questo!”
No, non sono giochi per computer,
sono giochi concreti tangibili.
A quel punto pensano che io sia
un piccolo aiutante di Babbo Natale
che faccio i trenini in legno
da mettere nelle confezioni.
Al che dico: "No, no, no, non giocattoli,
sono giochi da grandi, giochi..
insomma, giochi per adulti."
Sul 'giochi per adulti',
non vi dico cosa pensa la gente.
Insomma è veramente difficile
per me presentarmi.
Alla fine di solito ci riesco
e devo dire che una volta
che la gente capisce che faccio giochi,
è sempre molto interessata.
Mi fa un sacco di domande,
chiede da dove vengono le idee,
come si prepara un gioco.
Ma una cosa che tutti mi chiedono
prima o dopo è:
"Tu quando hai iniziato
ad occuparti di giochi?".
Quella per me
è una domanda difficile,
perché, a rigor di logica,
la risposta sarebbe questa:
"Io ero lì, in quella culla
e davanti a me c'era quella palla rossa
e mi è venuto in mente di...".
Perché quando mi fanno questa domanda
a me ne viene in mente un'altra
che di solito non rispondo,
ma : "Non è quando io ho iniziato,
ma quando tu hai smesso."
Quando smettiamo di divertirci?
Quando smettiamo di giocare?
Vorrei fare qui con voi
un piccolo esperimento.
Vi vedo?
Se vengo qui vi vedo.
Oh, bene, per l'esperimento
ringrazio le luci.
E vorrei anche prevedere
l'esito dell'esperimento.
Mai fatto in diretta.
L'esito dell'esperimento è:
meno del 10%.
Non sapete ancora di cosa però.
Ok, ora vorrei che tutti quanti
pensaste all'ultima volta
in cui vi siete divertiti.
Ci state pensando?
In prima, fila gli unici che vedo,
stanno sorridendo
quindi sì, ci stanno pensando.
Bene. E, quanto tempo
è passato intanto?
Chi ha pensato una cosa
nell'ultima settimana?
Adesso due settimane?
Un mese? Quest'anno?
Ok, ma oltre a quando è successo,
cosa stavate facendo?
Ora la domanda che ho previsto prima:
vorrei le mani alzate delle persone
che hanno pensato a qualcosa
che stavano facendo sul lavoro,
che stavano lavorando.
Altro che 10%. Qui siamo,
beh però ce ne sono, ce ne sono.
Bene, in realtà
qualcuno potrebbe pensare,
"Beh, è normale stavo lavorando,
non mi stavo divertendo."
Vedremo oggi. Io vi parlerò di gioco,
di divertimento e di lavoro.
Del rapporto che queste tre realtà
hanno avuto per me
e del rapporto che hanno
o più spesso non hanno
nella nostra società.
Nei prossimi 15 minuti daremo insieme
una nuova definizione di divertimento.
Vedremo come, applicandola,
non solo è importante,
ma è fondamentale,
che questa percentuale
cresca in maniera drammatica
e quali incredibili vantaggi
e benefici potremmo averne
a livello personale, professionale
ma soprattutto a livello sociale.
Partiamo da una nuova definizione
di divertimento.
O meglio, una seconda definizione.
Perché probabilmente quando
ho detto divertimento
molti hanno pensato a qualcosa
del genere, un momento di festa.
Questo è un divertimento,
ma non è quello di cui
vorrei parlarvi io oggi.
Vorrei parlarvi di qualcosa
che nel secolo scorso
un esperto di informatica e poi
un pedagogista han chiamato hard fun.
Seymour Papert ha dato
questa definizione
lavorando nel campo dell'educazione.
Ma ve la spiego ancora meglio
anche qui con un esempio.
Vorrei vedere la mano alzata
delle persone in sala
che hanno un figlio
dagli otto ai quindici anni.
Beh però, pensavo di più.
Sedici, to'.
Bene, ora pensate.
Una domanda scontata:
gioca al computer o alla playstation.
Ho sentito un "anche troppo".
Ora pensate all'espressione
che ha mentre sta giocando
e ditemi se è questa
o se è questa.
Qual è delle due?
È quella di destra, quasi sempre.
Il gioco è un tipo
di divertimento difficile.
Il gioco è qualcosa che ci sfida,
che richiede attenzione, concentrazione,
focus, problem solving.
È una cosa che a volte non ci riesce.
E questo è un tipo
di divertimento fondamentale
per la nostra dieta equilibrata
della nostra mente,
di quello che ha bisogno
la nostra mente.
È una delle cose
che molto spesso manca.
Vedete, dall'hard fun si passa subito...
Fra l'altro una definizione molto bella,
che rende molto l'idea:
divertimento difficile.
Si passa molto velocemente
anche al concetto dopo,
che è quello di flusso.
Questo è un concetto sviluppato
da Mihály Csíkszentmihályi.
Non mi chiedete di ripeterlo,
l'ho studiato prima cinque volte.
Comunque, uno psicologo che
negli anni '70 ha dato questa definizione.
Lui, vedete, ha passato la vita
studiando quelle attività
molto diverse fra loro che portavano
a degli stati di coinvolgimento estremo.
Lui ha studiato gli scacchi,
il golf, l'arrampicata e il ballo di coppia.
E tutti gli esperti e tutti i campioni
anche di queste attività
descrivevano la loro attività
tutti nello stesso modo,
come uno stato quasi di trance.
Tant'è che nello sport
si parla di trance agonistica.
Uno stato in cui anche
le nostre più basilari funzioni
come la necessità di sonno,
la stanchezza, la fame
vengono soppresse
e siamo totalmente partecipi
di quello che stiamo facendo.
In quei casi l'attività
diventa autotelica,
che significa piacevole in se stessa.
Non importa dove, cosa stiamo facendo,
se vinceremo, se perderemo:
farla è piacevole.
Beh, queste sono sicuramente
delle eccellenze che lui ha studiato.
Questo nel gioco accade molto,
molto spesso.
È anche il motivo per cui i ragazzi
stanno così tanto davanti ai computer,
perché entrano in uno stato di flusso.
Però forse parlando di queste attività
così estreme o di gioco,
forse non tutti possono condividere
quello che stiamo dicendo.
Ma in realtà, non è necessario
andare così lontano.
Pensate a quello
che tiene una donna in casa
che magari ha già lavorato
tutto il giorno, ha messo a posto,
ha fatto da mangiare,
anziché riposarsi
va a curare le piante dell'orto
o del giardino che tiene in balcone.
O un uomo che dopo
una giornata di lavoro,
anziché riposarsi si mette
in garage fino a mezzanotte
a smontare e a rimontare un motore,
per averlo poi come prima,
se non lo smontava.
Oppure un pescatore che si sveglia
alle cinque del mattino
in un giorno di festa
per andare a mettere gli stivali,
i piedi nell'acqua al buio e al freddo.
Queste sono cose che per un altro,
me per esempio,
sarebbero non solo lavori,
ma anche cose molto difficili da fare,
molto faticose.
Per loro, quello è un divertimento.
O meglio, è uno stato di flusso,
di questo tipo di sensazione,
di trance divertente.
Questa è una cosa fondamentale
per la nostra mente.
Dall'altra parte cosa abbiamo?
Abbiamo il lavoro.
Il lavoro è qualcosa
che mediamente occuperà
75 000 ore della nostra vita.
Quando tutto va bene.
In un anno di lavoro occuperà
un quarto del nostro tempo,
un terzo se togliamo le ore di sonno.
Non solo, il lavoro è quella cosa
che nella società ci definisce,
che diciamo quando ci presentiamo.
È il nostro ruolo nella società.
Verrebbe da pensare
che una cosa così importante
come questo coinvolgimento,
questa sfida di cui abbiamo bisogno
e una attività così pervasiva
come il lavoro si ritrovino.
No? Non sempre?
Con questa nuova definizione
che abbiamo dato di divertimento,
quand'è l'ultima volta
che ci siamo divertiti in questo senso?
L'ultima volta che non abbiamo sentito
il passare del tempo?
Che siamo stati lì fino a che
non abbiamo finito
quella cosa che stavamo facendo,
dimenticandoci di tutto.
E quella volta è stata al lavoro?
Forse. Forse per qualcuno.
O per qualcun altro lo è stato all'inizio
ma piano piano ha smesso di essere così.
Quindi la domanda,
oltre a quando smettiamo,
la domanda veramente importante è:
perché smettiamo?
Perché troppe volte, oggi
nella società, il lavoro è questo.
È quella cosa che ci sentiamo
costretti a fare
quando invece vorremo essere qui:
su una spiaggia a bere un mojito.
E lo facciamo solo
perché mettiamo da parte
le risorse economiche
e ci ritagliamo
quelle due settimane di tempo all'anno
in cui finalmente andare
sulla spiaggia e bere il mojito.
Perché sentiamo persone che dicono:
"Se vinco alla lotteria smetto di lavorare
e vado a prendere il sole ai Caraibi".
Quando invece,
se lo facessero veramente,
dopo dieci giorni
starebbero cercando due palme
alla distanza giusta per fare una porta
e una noce di cocco per giocare a calcio.
No, la noce di cocco non va bene,
comunque avete capito cosa intendo.
La nostra mente ci inganna.
Molto spesso, quando pensiamo
di avere bisogno di una pausa,
di una vacanza, invece
abbiamo bisogno di questo:
di hard fun, di flusso,
di cose che ci coinvolgano,
che ci impegnino,
che ci facciano risolvere problemi.
Nel modo giusto.
E la domanda al perché
tutto questo non funziona
ha una risposta molto semplice:
perché le regole sono sbagliate.
Da buon game designer, tutte le volte
che le regole sono sbagliate,
c'è una sola soluzione
che è quella di cambiarle.
Vedete, per me questa
è una cosa molto naturale,
molto semplice.
Io non solo ho giocato
da quando ero piccolo
e ho continuato a farlo, ma sempre
con questo atteggiamento:
sono stato incapace dall'inizio
di giocare ad un gioco
senza cercare di cambiarne le regole,
di farne una mia versione,
di fare dei miglioramenti.
Tant'è che spesso
i miei amici arrivavano a dire:
"Christian, stavolta facciamo
con le regole normali, eh?
Per una volta!"
Infatti, ce n'è anche qualcuno in sala
che potrà confermare.
E per voi oggi ho due buone notizie
e una un po' meno buona.
La prima buona notizia
è che le regole giuste
per iniziare a cambiare
l'ambiente del lavoro le sappiamo.
Ormai psicologia cognitiva,
economia comportamentale,
neuroscienze, game design
stanno tutti convergendo
verso le stesse risposte.
Iniziamo a capire come funzioniamo,
cos'è che ci motiva veramente,
cos'è che ci rende partecipi
e che fa rilasciare
al nostro corpo veramente
delle sostanze
che sono molto simili
a delle droghe naturali.
Noi siamo in grado
di autodrogarci:
la dopamina è una roba fortissima
che il nostro corpo può rilasciare.
Sappiamo come fare.
Vediamone insieme qualcuna,
ma non è una lista esaustiva,
ce ne sono veramente tante
che si potrebbero dire.
Ah, e molte di quelle
che vedremo, stranamente,
coincidono
con le buone regole di un gioco.
Avere obiettivi chiari.
Sapere esattamente
qual è il punto di arrivo
di quello che stiamo facendo,
con precisione.
E, non solo saperlo esattamente,
ma avere anche un feedback continuo.
Sapere e ci stiamo avvicinando
a quell'obiettivo
o se ci stiamo allontanando.
E saperlo a medio, a corto
e a lungo termine.
Avere una riposta sulla qualità
di quello che stiamo facendo.
Avere sfide bilanciate,
questo è importantissimo.
Avere delle sfide che siano misurate
alla nostra competenza.
Né troppo difficili, che generino
ansia, stress e preoccupazione
e né troppo facili
che ci facciano annoiare.
E, lo abbiamo visto poche sessioni fa
e mi sono trovato
completamente d'accordo:
interazione sociale.
Siamo animali sociali: non siamo fatti
per fare cose da soli.
Che sia cooperazione, collaborazione
come abbiamo visto poco fa,
o a volte anche competizione,
sana competizione.
Abbiamo bisogno
di relazionarci con gli altri.
Questa a me piace tantissimo:
sensazione di controllo.
Abbiamo bisogno di non sentirci
spettatori passivi
di quello che facciamo,
che eseguono e basta,
ma di avere in mano il volante
dell'auto che stiamo guidando.
Di sapere che stiamo facendo
scelte determinanti,
significative
per raggiungere l'obiettivo.
Predisposizione all'errore.
Questa era anche difficile
da scrivere, da intendere,
ve la dico a voce
che risulta meglio.
Quando giochiamo,
molto spesso perdiamo.
E questo ci deprime?
"Mi siedo a giocare?
Non lo so, forse perdo."
No, ci rende ottimisti.
Sul lavoro, troppo spesso, gli errori,
gli sbagli sono demonizzati,
esorcizzati e, per paura di farli,
nessuno cambia niente.
Perché si lascia tutto così,
così non ho colpa di niente.
"No ho colpa."
Mentre invece il cambiamento
è la base del miglioramento
e senza una predisposizione all'errore
non ci può essere
nessun tipo di cambiamento,
in nessuna realtà.
E infine, senso di miglioramento.
Non siamo fatti
per ripetere la stessa cosa.
Siamo fatti per fare
un passo avanti, aprire nuovi orizzonti
e iniziare a fare cose nuove,
cose più stimolanti
perché le nostre competenze
sono aumentate.
Quanti di questi punti valgono
nell'attività che state facendo?
Uno, due? Quattro
sarebbe già molto buono.
Perché non tutte?
Perché non tutti e sette
e anche qualcun altro magari.
La seconda buona notizia,
anche perché per molti
probabilmente pensare ad un lavoro
in cui questi punti valgano
risulta più avveniristico
dei robot dei questa mattina.
Al robot ci posso credere, ma questo!
In realtà, la seconda buona notizia
è che questo lo stiamo già facendo.
Moltissime aziende hanno già
introdotto nelle loro dinamiche,
all'interno, delle regole
tratte dal mondo dei giochi
per ottenere gli obiettivi
che abbiamo condiviso prima.
Non solo, addirittura, la Gartner,
che probabilmente
molti di voi conosceranno
che è la leader nel mondo
in fatto di analisi e predizione
sulla information technology,
ha previsto che nel 2015,
insomma domani,
il 70% delle fortune 500
applicherà regole
prese dal mondo dei giochi
all'interno della propria
organizzazione aziendale.
Vedete, questo è sempre stato --
le cose le sapevamo già.
Csíkszentmihályi e Papert
hanno vissuto nel secolo scorso,
cioè sono ancora vivi,
però le loro idee le hanno pensate
nel secolo scorso.
Quello che mancava fino ad oggi
era la condivisione.
Oggi grazie agli strumenti
di cui abbiamo parlato
durante tutta la giornata:
ai cloud, ai social,
alla mobilità delle piattaforme,
oggi queste esigenze
stanno emergendo.
La società si è resa conto
di quanto questo tipo
di coinvolgimento sia fondamentale.
Quello che manca, e qui la sfida,
è attuare il cambiamento.
Vedete, per me questa
è stata veramente un'epifania,
perché fino a qualche anno fa --
perché tutto questo
che vi sto dicendo
è veramente nato
negli ultimi tre anni.
E per me fino a questo momento
si era trattato
di vivere due vite parallele.
Di giorno avevo un lavoro normale,
in giacca e cravatta magari in ufficio
e la sera avevo la mia identità segreta,
cioè diventavo un game designer.
Eh? No?
Comunque, non riuscivo mai
a fonderle queste due realtà
perché sentivo
che nel gioco c'erano cose
che dall'altra parte
mi mancavano,
ma non avevo neanche le parole
per spiegarli questi concetti.
E per me scoprire che,
non solo degli altri game designer
se ne stanno occupando nel mondo,
ma che le trasformazioni
stanno già avvenendo
è stato veramente l'inizio
della mia sfida sociale.
E la mia sarà quella di far aumentare
la consapevolezza di questa necessità
e iniziare a implementare
queste trasformazioni,
questo cambiamento.
In una società che a sua volta
ha una sua sfida sociale,
che è quella di metterle in pratica.
Perché se quello
che abbiamo visto oggi
è vero per noi,
pensate a quanto è vero
per le nuove generazioni.
Le nuove generazioni, quelle
che entrano oggi nel mondo del lavoro
quelle che ci entreranno
nei prossimi dieci anni
con questo linguaggio ci sono nate.
Loro, il coinvolgimento,
l'engagement, lo conoscono
ed è l'unico linguaggio
che vogliono utilizzare.
Quindi abbiamo
come società due scelte.
La prima è quella
di continuare ad aumentare l'abisso
che si sta creando
tra quello che amano fare
e quello che dovranno fare.
Quella che è nota come
Engagement Crisis,
la crisi del coinvolgimento,
che è meno nota
della crisi finanziaria
che stiamo vivendo
ma è ugualmente importante
e preoccupante.
La secondo scelta è quella
di iniziare a imparare il loro linguaggio,
di iniziare a parlare
come loro e a dargli sfide
che vogliano affrontare,
dargli sfide che abbiano voglia
di iniziare a intraprendere.
Vedete, diciotto minuti
sono veramente pochi per dare risposte.
A me basterebbe
lasciarvi con una domanda.
Una domanda e un augurio.
La domanda è: come posso
iniziare questo cambiamento.
Di quale di quei punti
sento di più la mancanza
e come posso nella mia realtà
iniziare a metterlo in pratica.
E l'augurio è che magari
a qualche mese da qui,
ripensando alle domande
che ci siamo fatti oggi insieme:
"Quand'è l'ultima volta
che mi sono divertito,
che ho provato flusso,
che ho provato hard fun",
magari molti possano pensare
a qualcosa avvenuto
nelle ultime 48 ore,
ma che davvero l'80,
il 90% possa pensare
a qualcosa avvenuto sul lavoro.
Perché, se questo è vero
per quelli di voi
che sono responsabili
solo di se stessi
sarebbe importante
che lo fosse ancora di più
per le persone fra di voi
che gestiscono un gruppo,
o addirittura guidano un'azienda.
Perché questo è l'inizio
della trasformazione di cui c'è bisogno.
e questa credo davvero che sia un'idea
che vale la pena diffondere.
Grazie e buon divertimento.
(Applausi)